people are always so excited to see you
and I'm just trying to imagine what is
it like to be John Claude Van Damme I
mean when you go places people must get
very excited if you're just out in the
world if you're getting off a plane and
walking through the airport people must
go nuts yes they like me so much on the
database way yes yeah but a story about
that when I came to the US when people
come to the airport
some people are very emotional and when
they come to the customs you know if
they officer look at them like you know
like this for a sec you know they get
very nervous and did I did something
wrong right yeah so I'm coming to the to
the customs in Los Angeles and you know
I'm Jean Claude Van Damme I've got my
hand and and again look at me anything
or like I go I've done something wrong I
don't know you never know maybe you know
so I'm coming there it's a passport oh
man Jean Claude Van Damme you know we
come out of his booth he look left and
right you do the split okay paper yeah
he's been waiting his whole life and
that's so he do the split for you right
buddy stay very any you know in this
very serious but I mean but he took the
Charmy yes the time to show you a real
testament for those uniform pants yeah
yeah they just tear yeah
you